meow wolf is an art collective turned
production company ultimately it's a
social
impact art project this exhibition here
at area 15
is basically an immersive experience
that begins
in this grocery store omega mart as you
move through the store you'll find this
is
absolutely not your typical grocery
store
eventually you'll probably find your way
into some portals
into a parallel dimension when you move
into that
parallel dimension there are art
installations from artists from
all over the world that are on display
it's sort of like walking through
a series of dreams we've gotten to work
with
dozens of really brilliant local artists
and a lot of their work is on display
here
in omegamart they all kind of merge and
blend together in different ways it's
really hard to say where one thing stops
and another
begins this is the culmination of 13
years of work for me personally and for
my my fellow uh co-founders and the
meowthers that have been
involved from the from day one we have
tickets on sale right now
at omegamart.com tickets are yeah start
at 45 dollars
and we have a local discount for anybody
that lives in the area